I just stay home and play my dick all
day that's all I do my ideal day as a
man starts with me peeing standing up I
want to know the way it feels to pee or
the difference between boxers and boxer
briefs
jackoff because I think that's what they
do right you know talk about what I'm
playing with her boobs a lot it's like
it's just you can be interesting to see
like what it's like to feel threatening
cuz I never feel threatening no one has
ever afraid of me so I'd really like to
test that I would always walk around
with my pelvis like facing forward
because I'm a man and like you know my
dick is everything then I would hit the
streets and start talking to the lady
cuz I think I'd be really good at it is
a guy's see if I can check them out in a
way that makes them feel good about
themselves I would treat women with
respect I'd give them flowers and roses
I think it's been the entire day with my
shirt off oh yeah I would definitely I
would spray a [ __ ] ton of axe under my
ridiculously hairy armpit look at my
penis and be like well thanks God and go
for this round and just have tons of
chicks just like running after me I have
sex a lot all the time probably and then
you know I'd like to lead some sort of
meeting oh I would take an eggplant
Friday so I'd like to have a whiteboard
and a pen and make people listen to me I
think I jack off again before that I'd
also like to just kind of talk to
strangers in a confident and assuming
way by this time it's six o'clock I'm
looking at my penis again trying to
figure out what to do with it
and then I probably go to sleep I think
it'd be a really good day